best but but here's what i did let me
tell you what happened with me so i'm
coming up in business and i'm learning
from these advisors and mentors and the
rule of thumb in business is what never
talk religion never talk sex and never
talk uh uh politics right these are like
the three things whatever other things
that people want to add to it i'm like
you know what
um
i don't know i like talking religion i
like talking politics and i don't mind
talking about sex because at that time
i'm single so i'm like i'm dealing with
a bunch of young guys yeah hey they want
to talk about it talk about it right and
then you are smaller
so when you're smaller and you're doing
it the risk is higher
as you're getting bigger and you're
doing it you have a little bit more
credibility but it comes to a point
where you are managing expectation with
the audience and let me explain to what
i mean by this
first time i did a a interview with
michael francis and i did a mob
interview and then after that i then
reviewed 20 other mobsters and we did a
bunch of different things but the first
time i did it i can't believe pat did
this you should have never done this
you're an idiot you're this why would
you associate yourself and pop up i'm
like it's my show it's what i'm
interested in yeah if you're not don't
worry about it yeah exactly there's 50
million other channels and i started
interviewing bodybuilders why would a
business channel interview bodybuilders
why would you have on dorian yes why
would you have on this person listen i
like bodybuilding you don't like it go
elsewhere yeah then i was inter so then
why is pat talking so much politics why
pat talking cia people why is talking to
communists this is a business channel
you shouldn't interview 10 communist
professors and all these other guys they
hate america listen it's my channel yeah
so what i'm doing in that moment with my
fans my audience i'm managing
expectations
this is what i like you like it great
you don't you don't like it i think in
business like yesterday i'm giving a
message the whole message i gave
yesterday at the closing session was
about politics
and then the story i told i told the
following story i said
when 9 11 happened
and uh uh everybody is looking around
saying wait a minute two planes that's
the enemy are you kidding me no problem
what are you black you're white i don't
care where's your kid i'm gonna go help
you yeah you're republican you're a
democrat i don't give a [ __ ] if you're
republican or democrat today we're all
americans right what happened the last
two years with covet is
we said covet came and
say china's the one that caused a lot of
this rather than saying that's the enemy
we said you're a republican before i'm
an american i'm a democrat before i'm an
american we forgot the fact that we're
americans first before we're political
issues now
ten years ago twelve years ago i had
dinner with george one and i first
talked politics
people said you shouldn't talk about
that and i'm like so i was a little bit
on edge myself yeah man maybe i
shouldn't talk about this in business
because i'm losing people right
and then eventually i said
five years i'm asking myself i can't
stop talking about this stuff this is
all i think about so my manager of
expectation with the audience was
this is what i talk about if you're
uncomfortable you can go to another
company of course but this is my comfort
zone so i think as a comedian
you are essentially
you know because you you can get lost
and seeing one guy goes viral as a
committee i'm like maybe i should try
that guy selling one guys on maybe i
should get like dude that's just not my
style yep this is my style what do you
want me to do and then you stick to it
and you manage that expectation with
your audience 100
and that's why none i didn't lose a
single fan during that entire thing
without a doubt everyone knows that
that's my thing so when people come and
see me live if i don't have
something that's
you know
really put really pushing the limit uh
that's then they're not getting they
feel like you treated them yeah they're
like what are you doing bro you push the
limit all we did was laugh the whole
time meanwhile i need to get them to
literally go oh
god
that's all i did when i was listening to
you yeah i'm telling you i was listening
i'm like freaking hey this guy's
unbelievable
i love if you haven't been have you have
you seen us uh not live i've seen it as
obviously i i thought i thought i
thought tony's message
was unreal hans was third you came right
before uh uh
joe and then joe came up and joe did
what joe did yeah but uh dude you were
just going like this you were going like
this and it's funny watching you how you
handled at first one of the mics wasn't
working they brought the new mic and
you're just in control you're dressed in
your you know thing that you have and
you did what you did but
again i want
you to be free yeah you know i want
comedians to be free i want a comedian
to offend me go ahead and say something
middle eastern armenian say something
okay i want to hear it but but it better
be funny let me make me laugh what's my
balls but i think that's what you guys
are saying that in your world if you can
make it funny 100 yeah well let me let
me ask you guys tony yeah sorry well i
mean look i think comedians have a very
necessary role in society especially
right now in america today i think
as far as we talked about this the whole
conversation basically started on i
remember when i almost got canceled
right so we're talking about cancer
culture right now comedians have a
longer leash than any other person in
america whether you're a business person
ceo whether you're a politician whether
you're just average joe show on the
street comedians have that ability to
say
i could push the envelope i can push the
limit here look at from you know lenny
bruce yep who got canceled yeah get
thrown in jail yeah to carlin
you know who turned from basically from
a comedian to the philosopher's head to
a modern day pundit even and then you
have um
richard pryor and everything that he was
doing eddie murphy but like these days
right now
uh louis ck got [ __ ] cancelled yeah
for doing something not even a joke some
some other stuff some other stuff yeah
okay yeah got swept up in the metoo
movement yeah okay but he got cancelled
by
hollywood though correct totally
different but then he's selling his own
specials and selling out
here
in the world there's a there's a reason
he's not headlining like he was before
but here's my point but he is here's my
point okay
dave chappelle they tried to cancel dave
chappelle right yeah whether you believe
that or not but they tried to cancel
[ __ ] rogan right of course like
everything is like the end the end the
the da
but if there's anybody that's not
cancelable cancel a bull it's the
biggest
the people the biggest microphones and
the biggest leash are comedians as a
comedian do you feel a sense of
responsibility to say
all right things are kind of crazy here
in america right now let me i gotta add
my like tim dillon is great at this kind
of stuff like that right yeah do you
feel a sense of like
hey you can't cancel me i'm a freaking
comedian like this is kind of my job
here what are your thoughts on just
overall component of what it's like to
be a comedian and your role in society
see what i'm saying here yeah i mean
totally yeah we are
it's already proven i mean what you just
said about louie being canceled or dave
chappelle being cancelled or to them
trying to cancel joe rogan like none of
that is a thing we did 15 000 people on
wednesday dave chappelle will always
sell out whatever he wants to do anybody
that's ever seen louie unless you've
literally had somebody in a hotel room
jerk off in front of you he didn't lose
a fan i mean
these you know you can't cancel that
which works if it's not funny that's
different yeah but you you can't cancel
comedians it's just impossible what you
can do what the one option is is you
have to hope that they get arrested like
bill cosby
is cancelled yeah right but he's out in
our lives even though he's free and if
he if he doesn't stand up he'd sell out
in a heartbeat he would sell out with
his crowd in a heartbeat bunch of creeps
bill cosby would 100 percent sell out in
in hours
arena whatever trust me so but tony just
said something very important though
tony if you don't mind unpacking that
you said but louis ck got cancelled with
hollywood not cancer so unpack what that
means so he was writing and directing
and producing and acting and those
things you're leaving it into these
corporations hands all of a sudden and
the second that that happens you've
given it and you've given it to them you
know what i mean luckily
you know netfl even netflix was put on
the pressure cooker with the chappelle
stuff it wasn't chappelle who was
getting hurt by it it was them right
because they're going netflix take this
down or else you're against transgender
whatever which if you listen to the joke
there's nothing to even be mad at at all
it's just him covering a subject getting
laughs being actually
a supporter of transgender rights but
nobody listens to anything it doesn't
matter and what they're saying doesn't
matter those people that
the twitter mobs and everything they
don't they don't care at all they're
bored they're always looking for their
next thing
and you know they're always moving on
but getting canceled by hollywood i mean
he wanted to do that stuff and now and i
know what's going to happen he's going
to make things with his own money
and he's going to make more money
because the next thing that's going to
be the next thing or perhaps the tide is
turning as we're seeing with netflix and
disney and hbo
winning this race because why because
they're they tend to stick with
absolutely good content it's not about
this or pandering towards this i mean
the most watched most awarded show right
now is succession it's the only thing
that i'm really that an ozark right it's
like two of the most
lauded things and it's about what rich
white people making vast sums of money
yeah so like
meanwhile other other shows are like hey
come over here for black history month
or it's asian heritage month we have
these special asian shows and people are
starting to catch on like why are you
why are you pandering to me because
that's what they think that people want
because everybody's so woke right now
and meandering is the way in our world
in being a comedian that's the lowest
form yeah it's not it's pandering yeah
is trying to oh this is a black audience
so i'm going to sound a little bit
blacker this is worse i'm going to do
these jokes because this this this if
you enjoyed the short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]